hello everyone and welcome back to the
show that today takes two of the
scariest cinema studios of the modern
era and tosses them into a pit to duke
it out for eternal glory now normally
that would sound frightening but with
plum house and 824 the prospect of
competing on a show called versus
actually seems like a relaxing stroll in
the park compared to what we normally
witness in their films today's episode
will be focusing on the horror and
fright adjacent films that these odd
chair houses have cranked out since
their inception and it's going to be a
doozy that will keep us sleeping with
one eye open gripping your pillow tight
exit the big budgets but keep the
blockbusters these two movie studios are
beloved by filmmakers and audiences
alike even while keeping their costs low
a24 and blumhouse have managed to create
some of the scariest films and
franchises in talking picture history
all while spending less than i make in a
month doing this show yes i get paid to
do this in coupons they're the money of
the 1990s i've watched this video enough
i'm starting to feel bad for the kid in
one corner you have blumhouse the
production entity made famous by flicks
like get out and split and franchises
like paranormal activity and insidious
in the other corner it's indy darling
a24 whose art house has been turned into
myth by films like the witch hereditary
and under the skin and they've released
scary movies made by everyone from denny
villeneuve to kevin smith two art focus
studios going at it and possibly the
most ambitious verses of the season who
begins to write this all right me
good luck i knew it
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
villains round four iconic moments and
then we'll do a wild card round that
could involve anything from lighthouse
shenanigans to creepy home movies and
whoever wins i probably lose not only
did i spend a week watching virtually
every horror movie from these two
studios now i'm gonna have to break the
news to one of them that the other one
is better you know what that's like to
have toby the demon stand at the side of
your bed with his weird goat feet or how
about when you upset someone north of
the wall and for funsies they slowly
turned you into a walrus why did i agree
to do this why
oh yeah the fast food coupons rallies
here i come but first an epic versus the
likes of which we may never see again
also there's gonna be a lot of scary
imagery so put the kids to bed now i
don't care what time it is they need to
learn that sleep is the most important
meal of the day or let them watch i
don't care about my kids right
right okay good 8 24 in blumhouse
fighters ready let's get it on round one
box office
what's the best part about making cheap
movies it doesn't matter if anyone comes
out to see them you're bound to turn a
profit because your investment was so
minimal but occasionally unlike me in
las vegas a24 and blumhouse have hit the
jackpot of the multiplex ringing up cash
registers like their slot machines at
the tropicana wow okay thanks for the
psychoanalysis yet while blumhouse has
had some huge scores in their day a24
takes a more tortoise approach than hair
to date they've had no films crossed the
legendary 100 million dollar worldwide
box office benchmark but they still
found their way into some big hits
hereditary is the all-time breadwinner
for the brand notching 81 million
dollars at the bo ariaster also directed
824's second highest hauling film
midsomar which raked in 46 million
dollars then robert eggers said hold my
brew and made the witch which soared to
a 40 million dollar take from there
however it's mostly single-digit
millions which includes critically
adored fare like the killing of a sacred
deer at six million dollars enemy at
four million dollars and ghost story
grossed two million dollars and again
we're only focusing on horror flicks
today so incredible works like moonlight
will be riding the bench in fact i only
let ghost story in because i mean it's
it's a ghost so it's a very well behaved
one but still a ghost nonetheless hey
just saying it's gonna be an uphill
climb for a 24 in this round because
blumhouse has picked up a few franchises
along the way the dubafo enough box
office to contend with the disney's and
universals of the world in fact
blumhouse has had four films to date
that have crossed the 200 million dollar
standard split halloween get out and
paranormal activity 3 which is the one
where they put a camcorder on a fan
okay we'll get to that later it's pretty
cool right yeah
consider this a24 entire horror movie
catalog has combined a gross 272 million
dollars split made 278 million dollars
on its own thanks wacky twist ending
rejoice
13 more blumhouse flicks have crossed
the 100 million dollar line including
franchise faves like the first two
paranormal activity films insidious the
last key and the purge anarchy which may
be the best punisher movie i've ever
seen but i love you too warzone
you have to let me go and the very first
insidious and the end night shyamalan
comeback vehicle to visit both got
within a couple million bones of hitting
a hundred million dollars so now we'll
look at averages just to notarize this
round as a big w for the house of blum
a24 films average a 15 million dollar
global take compared to drum roll please
77 million dollars for blumhouse in
total the blum movies have consumed 4.5
billion bucks and with sterling
franchise staying power that number
could keep climbing sooner rather than
later we haven't heard the last of a24
but round one goes to blumhouse and they
take an early lead one to nothing we
handle
round two tomato meter slash audience
score i love every single audience
member that works hard pays for a ticket
to see a movie and doesn't take out
their cell phone even once i'll even
appreciate a kid who paid for a ticket
to see beethoven second just they could
sneak into lethal weapon 3.
and it is indeed that audience that
could hold sway in this round as well
and with that setup trivia time can you
name the first horror feature released
by blumhouse and or a24 what is that i
have a point in asking this i swear for
blumhouse it's 2009's paranormal
activity 824 kicked things off in 2014
with enemy and now the point i was
arriving at these flicks kind of started
the template for creepy crawly things to
come with future releases loved by
critics not quite as much with the
audience now usually with a scary movie
pick any leprechaun film you want it's
going to do better with the audience
score metric than with the tomato meter
but that's not the case here the ogpa is
at a sterling 83 percent on the may
today tomato but only 57 with the
audience enemy scored a 71 with critics
and cooled off with a 64 with the good
people opening weekend so this round may
in fact come down to who pleased more of
us than folks on this planet who paid
money to see batman returns and then
snuck into terminator 2.
hasta la vista baby the highest rated
movie according to the tomato meter for
either house is
not get out that's at 98 and it's a
stone cold classic but creep 2 is at 100
percent that's toy story quality right
there
oh impressive wingspan very good which
is fitting because through a certain
lens buzz and woody have a lot in common
with people like annabelle chucky and
pinocchio all of whom are horror movie
villains i'm sorry but a wooden puppet
who's suddenly singing about no string
to hold him down is terrifying oh jiminy
leave me out of this a24 has a slew of
films in the 90s including their highest
rated double feature of x and krisha at
95 percent followed closely by saint
maud at 93 percent in fabric at 91
percent then four movies tied at 90
including two robert edgar's delights
the witch and the lighthouse are there
as is a ghost story and green room for
plum house it's hush cam and sweetheart
knotted up at 93 percent followed by the
invisible man at 92 percent and the gift
at 91 percent be nice to your high
school classmates i promise it pays off
later in life wow that's great
um well i am sorry and uh maybe we can
get together sometime and uh and have
some coffee or something
sure i'd like that okay we get it the
critics love them some blum 24. ooh if
they ever team up i think we know the
name that we're calling them it's the
best company crossover since moland
springs but even fancy art studios have
a few bad apples in the bushel for
blumhouse that could mean movies like
fantasy island at eight percent fire
started 11 percent or ouija at 6 percent
happily the prequel ouija origin of evil
did the unthinkable and rebounded all
the way up to 83
on the tomato meter that might be the
biggest comeback in any franchise ever
and it's also a great reminder to never
ever use a ouija board i even felt weird
typing the word no thank you hometown
it's only a game a24 never reached the
depths of an uh o-u-i-j-a they actually
only have two movies in the 20s dark
places is the low bar at 23 wood shock
is at 26 then we can leap all the way up
to the 40s with films like tusk at 46
percent and false positive at 48 percent
and now a24 looks to surge ahead because
they only have six horror kind of films
that are rotten at all on the tomato
meter blumhouse well they have uh more i
lost count after 40. aren't you tired
all told both studios have a pretty
solid average with their scary treats
with a24 fresh at 75 per flick and
blumhouse rotten but respectable with a
52 per cinematic outing so now we look
to the audience who as we now know tends
to be harsher critics than the
professional movie reviewers themselves
really
all right on the audience score a24
jumps up to 15 films that are rotten
including men at 40 percent and it comes
at night at 44 percent blumhouse has
some franchises hitting the skids in the
20s with the craft legacy at 24
paranormal activity the ghost dimension
at 26
and the first purge at 27
even the purge anarchy which is
considered by me to be the citizen kane
of movies
only made it up to 56 with the audience
so it's been a happy spin on this round
you the very judgey people of earth do
happen to enjoy some of these films
enough to get them back to fresh the
black phone is the high mark for
blumhouse at 91 currently followed by
get out at 86 percent for 824 it's the
hole in the ground at 83 percent
followed by krisha at 77 percent to the
average as we go blumhouse dips on the
audience score metric notching just 45
per movie a 24 slides as well but just
down to 54
meaning they will take the win in terms
of the audience the critics and now
round two that's the first point of
their afternoon and the match is tied
one to one
[Applause]
round three villains
and now the reason why we see these
movies in the first place it's not for
the heroes or the helpers or the good
side of human nature it's because we
like to see bad stuff go down from the
safe friendly confines of a cinema
screen boy do we have a host of baddies
nerdy wells and even unseen spirits that
wreak havoc upon those poor unsuspecting
fools who just moved into a new house or
settling into a green room or the
dummies who didn't take my advice and
effed around with a ouija board look i
don't believe in it but i don't not
believe in it either no it doesn't sound
crazy at all for plum house one might
naturally conjure memories of the first
time we saw toby's antics in paranormal
activity i hear he's a nice guy where he
gets to know him but a demon nonetheless
how come my face is scratched in yours
speaking of demonic tudors it's not just
a magic the gathering card banned from
tournament play it's also an apt
description for darth maul's little
brother from insidious such a cool look
and really makes venturing into that
netherworld a thankless task let's also
shout out amateur film student bagool
and both vince vaughn and catherine
newton as millie and the butcher in the
body swap nightmare freaky shake [ __ ]
[Music]
right over at a24 we have a witch who
definitely is in the same weight class
as the duck for monty python and the
holy
grail dress her up like this no no no no
no no no yes yes yes
and i don't really trust that goat at
all phillip from the get-go just didn't
look right and i don't want my kids
playing with him hereditary has a bevy
of scary demons that would rival toby
led by payment all told there's 72
demons and hereditary geez that means we
could get like 71 sequels right get to
work arya astor fine
speaking of sir aster he also treated us
to mid-some are where we get weird stuff
ranging from old folks who can't wait to
fly to a bear costume and if you like
gaggles of crazy white folks get out as
having your cake and eating it too just
don't drink the tea bradley whitford
finally gets a role so evil it rivals
his award-winning turn as eric and billy
madison eric
you're gonna give the company to eric he
is a bad bad man
similarly lacking in business ethics his
wife catherine keener who we had come to
trust thanks to fun comedies like the 40
year old virgin wow were we in for a
change-up how do you feel now and you're
just as bad allison williams the
daughter i trusted you for 45 good
minutes a24 may not spend a ton of bread
but they've still given us some really
neat creature features like under the
skin which featured an alien that looks
remarkably like black widow speaking of
spiders they're all over the place an
enemy and that is a top contender for
segway of the year
that's good
that is good
we also been bestowed with a walrus guy
courtesy of kevin smith's tusk and
whatever that lamboy thing is in the
well-titled film lamb blumhouse has
everything from scary roommates to
killers on the loose and that's just in
happy death day technology rules the day
and is used for non-good in the
invisible man so i guess we can blame
that suit a little bit it's kind of evil
and speaking of inanimate objects the
lighthouse itself from the accurately
called film the lighthouse drives its
inhabitants insane and gives them the
worst on-camera gastrointestinal issues
since swiss army man
and then there's the board of which we
do not speak of in the o movies plus the
cameo in the paranormal activity
franchise also worthy of praise is the
underwater aquaplex in the deep house
and their grenade in fantasy island it's
like their version of a thermal
detonator there's nothing better than
the um
grandparents in the visit and james
mcavoy breaking both good and very very
very bad and split he's done awful
things to people and he'll do awful
things to you i have blue socks too but
as a kid who is much more freaked out by
the exorcist than freddie jason and
mikey combined it's the sites unseen
that sometimes scare us the most and for
all the mayhem caused by toby for me
it's the a24 team-up of payment payments
verbit fan base and the slow creep of
the witch that gets me leaning towards
a24 here and then we get amber slashing
tummies in green room so yeah a24 gets
the w in the most competitive round yet
they now have two points and blumhouse
needs a win in the next stage round four
iconic moments
if blumhouse wants a w here they're
gonna have to earn it why is that more
than any other genre horror movies have
given us moments that can shock awe and
terrify and when you see him in a movie
theater opening night it's almost always
followed by a collective laugh by the
crowd at how we just got got it's
nothing better
if it's a point jason blum and company
need they back some solid franchises to
achieve it the purge has too many
baddies to mention and they range from
street dwellers to high on the hog
politicos and even though we slide the
purge anarchy in as a horror movie big
props to frank grillo for just kicking
so much ass throughout that entire movie
when all crime becomes legal for 12
hours let's all meet at grillo's pad
look at my face okay you remember me
also in the house of blum is paranormal
activity which did far more than just
kick things off for the studio in the
right direction that one series has
given us more thrills chills and sleep
denial than just about any other horror
property ever and for me things peaked
when we did hit part three and how many
times you say that about a scary flick
it's pretty much nightmare almost three
three the dream warriors and paranormal
activity three the oscillating fan
remember it okay so as soon as we see
that trick we know it's gonna freak us
out we buckle up but we still get scared
on such a primal level even the lesser
paranormals have built-in frights that
will tickle our spine and keep the
lights on until morning then we arrive
at insidious long before stranger things
showed us the upside down and pre-dating
get out's the sunken place we got the
netherworld introduction by the great
lin shea that mirrored our own reality
with a horrifying fun-house mirror
sinister added to the blumhouse cannon
with a perfect mix of terrifying images
jump scares and just enough twists and
turns to keep us on our toes oh i did
mention get out right oh
no
no
no
no no no no no no no no no no our
introduction to this bizarre sith mind
trick was seeing very odd jogging in the
middle of the night and witnessing a
maid only be able to muster a single
teardrop as a means of crying for help
daniel kaluuya is terrific and little
rel howery is a much needed comic relief
that never fails to knock a lion out of
the stadium i mean i told you not to go
in the house
well that's a lot of blumhouse gushing
mark you handsome devil is what everyone
rooting for a24 is screaming me i was
just screaming throughout the entire
second half of hereditary especially
when we all learned the lesson that
sticking your head out of a car window
is a stunt best left to molly the wonder
dog a climax filled with fire brimstone
and pagan rituals manages to supersede
our expectations up to that point which
is impressive because the movie had me
from the word go you're never going to
look at a barbie dream house the same
way
midsummer continued the trend of graphic
depictions of inventive ways to meet
one's end those old folks they seem
thrilled to get their moment in the sun
and the way arya astor films that
sequence is just so stunning in its
simplicity and its finality those two
they're definitely in the nfl concussion
protocol
the witch leans on northeast mythology
to summon a suspenseful master class in
pacing and paying off at the end
thomason taking flight with her new uh
occupation is worth the build up and
again i cannot stress this enough goats
are not toys stick with the video games
children
the violent portrayals in a24 fair like
green room and under the skin are
handled with such inventiveness that it
never feels like torture porn even as
characters are losing their literal
bodies to an insidious entity thanks for
the loan blumhouse and then we get
downright weird with a podcast gone very
wrong and tusk and it just gets stranger
with lamb my all-time moment for this
entire studio though might be in the
black coat's daughter it's an exorcism
with a side of what's the h it's very
rare to say don't go to a freaking demon
but that movie pulls it off however the
sheer volume of blumhouse offerings
really gives it a shot in the arm in
this round for every franchise moment
like when the purge kicks off there's
also one-offs that stay with you like
the cool ending to oculus that made me
not look in a mirror for an entire month
the final showdown in black christmas or
the hallway tussle on the invisible man
are also worthy of praise in the end
pound for pound these two movie houses
are deadlocked in a tie so i gotta go
with blumhouse for being so prolific
with quality content since 2009. they
have the round that they needed to take
and the ball game is once again tied two
to two i never should have listened to
you this is all your fault
and now it's time for the wild card
round you all ready for this
ah too unlimited they had you all ready
for this and twilight zone is their
biggest jock jam hits which are still
played at virtually every basketball
game from madison square garden to the
fabulous forum or the staples center or
crypto world wherever the lakers play
now the point is our expert researcher
mark hoffmeyer had a spectacular
tie-breaking concept in the vein of
hoops that i will now borrow and take
credit for because one it's a great idea
and two it makes my job a lot easier
okay you see basketball features two
teams battling it out for glory rings
and greatness that are each comprised of
five starting players you see where
we're going with this yet so for
blumhouse and a24 i'm going to give them
each five films to represent their squad
the best of the best the fabest five in
the fifedom to the winner will go the
point in this round and thus win the
match it's a cool concept right glad i
thought of it get the [ __ ] out of here
for blumhouse your starting lineup is
get out paranormal activity three split
insidious and the invisible man just
think of how many players james mcavoy
can guard with all those personalities
of his it might get weird in the locker
room though everybody just take a minute
and now the starting lineup for a24
hereditary green room x under the skin
and number 23 from north carolina the
witch
a note to michael jordan i did not just
compare you to a witch you used your
supernatural powers for good it was just
a fun introductions joke thanks as
always for watching the program mj
hasn't missed a show yet
what's going on here and now to settle
things on the court what i love about
both squads is the variety with which
they can scare us divergent tactics like
found footage work for paranormal
activity 3 super violent sequences rule
the day for green room but the star of
a24 is hereditary simple because it's
the perfect mesh of quiet unsettling
nerves fraying like in the witch but
then we're rewarded for sitting on the
edge of our seat with sequences that
make x and green rooms most horrific
imagery look like child's play
bomb house features a nice combo of
crowd-pleasing blockbusters like the
invisible man and get out but they have
more than just popcorn pushing as a
purpose there's some deep themes going
on here and for all the surprise scares
we receive thanks to pa3 and insidious
it's the psychological freights courtesy
of the human condition that truly stand
out with get out the invisible fella and
even split a24 uses more subversive
angles to weave a masterful tail the
witch and under the skin can sneak up on
you x can strongly caution one against
swamp creatures and then there's green
room just waiting to bludgeon your
eyeballs for a hundred straight minutes
it's [ __ ] hard man i've been in many
a bad comedy club green room but nothing
like that movie i will never again
complain about a lawn chair and a broken
mini-fridge
clubs you know who you are careful now
but for all the greatness of a24 and
their incredibly powerful filmmaking
stable the pick and roll offense of a
plus social commentary like get out and
the invisible man make for a formidable
duo insidious gives us your more classic
style scare fest with frightful delights
around every corner split is an acting
graduate course and paranormal activity
3 is just pure found footage fun and
that's coming from a guy who loved the
visit and was tempted to put that movie
in instead
hereditary and the witch are all timers
for me but as a whole i feel like team
blumhouse lasts deeper into a
nail-biting seven-game series and
obviously they have the more potent
bench when it's time to put in the
reserves this should be a fun battle to
revisit down the road but for right now
to get a win in this game this series
this round and now the match it goes to
blumhouse twas an all-timer here kids
and whichever way i went i really
couldn't go wrong which is a nice way of
saying there was no way i could be 100
right
see ya make sure you keep your eyes
peeled to the great new content that
seems to emerge from these two studios
on a weekly basis when you see blumhouse
you know you're in for a great horror
ride and that a24 logo can signal a good
scary story but it may also be a
hard-hitting drama or something so
wholly inventive it defies sexualization
at your local blockbuster video if you
live in bend oregon and as always this
is all just my humble opinion now it's
your turn earth the other seven planets
and whatever we're currently labeling
pluto as hit me up on social media with
your take as to who is the better studio
at mark ellis live and keep it tuned
right here to rotten tomatoes for all
the latest in movies tv and other things
that will scare the crap out of us
thanks for watching versus i'm mark
ellis and for goodness sakes keep your
head inside the car while on the road to
grandmas actually given the events of
the visit uh just turn that car around
and go back home you'll thank me later
don't talk to ghosts
[Music]